What's up, brother? Um, I have a
question from earlier. You were having a
conversation about abortion. Yeah. Yes.
Um, well, I I I'm a trinitarian. I I'm a
Christian, you know. I I I sin like all
of us, but we all do. Yeah. What I don't
understand about abortion is
Jesus never forced his religion on
anybody. So, I just don't see why I
should have to force my religion and my
beliefs on people. I don't understand
what you're saying. What's that got to
do with abortion? I'm pro-choice.
Pro-choice. You know, I I Then you're
antiible. I'm not. No, no. I'm not pro I
don't believe people should have
abortions,
but I understand why. I I feel like a
lot of people understand. Why do you
understand it? I I I
um I I I just think part a lot of uh
pro-life people are hypocrites. And But
you're a hypocrite, too. And you're
pro-choice, so you just condemn
pro-choice because you're a hypocrite.
I'm I'm not. No, I'm not trying to
condemn anybody. I'm trying Listen,
listen. I'm trying to explain to you if
you don't get in. Okay. Sorry. If your
grounds for being pro-choic is because
proifers are hypocrites. Are you a
hypocrite?
I try not to be. I don't care if you try
not to be. Are you a hypocrite?
I don't think so.
No. Let me Hold on. Let me talk to Butch
for a minute. Hold on. Let's talk to
Butch. No. No. No. No. Okay. Do you know
pro-choices who are hypocrites?
I do. Okay. So, now notice, be
consistent. You're condemning proiffers
cuz they're hypocrites, but you just
said you know pro-choicers who are
hypocrites. So, why don't you condemn
pro-choice? Be consistent. I I do.
That's why I'm I'm trying to talk to you
and trying to understand, Sam. Yeah. But
I'm helping you reason out if you follow
me. Your argument against pro-life is
inconsistent. If they're hypocrites and
somehow that means you're against pro-
life, then be against pro-choice because
there are hypocrites among them as well.
That's what I'm trying to show you the
first step. Okay? So, I think it's not a
good argument to be pro-choice and
against pro-life because there are
hypocritical pro-lifeers because there
are hypocritical pro-choicers. So,
condemn it both. So, then Okay.
Okay. I I just don't want to be a
hypocrite myself, you know. Yeah, but
they're hypocrites on both camps. So,
why aren't you Okay, I agree. I agree. I
I agree 100%. So, aren't you neither?
Uh well, I just I Well, I guess I am
neither. I mean, I I just feel that we
should have the freedom to do as we
please. You know what I mean? Okay. So,
where where do you put a limit freedom?
So, if a man wants to marry his mother
and says, "That's my free choice. I want
to commit incest." Will you then fight
for legislation for that? No. No. No.
You're inconsistent. Why?
I I mean, if they they want to marry
their mother, that's up to them. They
have to answer to God. I don't have But
would you fight for their right? Would
you fight for legislation to give them
that right?
What do you mean fight for it? I don't I
In other words, would you be on their
side to get legislators to legislate
incest?
No. Oh, I'm not going to sign a bail or
sign anything that says you're doing
that with pro-choice, though. Why are
you inconsistent?
What's that? Why are you inconsistent?
Would you join pro-lifees to get
legislators to condemn abortion or would
you say no? They have a right to abort
even though I don't agree with it. If
you say yes, then why don't you do that
for incest?
Well, I don't really I don't sign
anything that you know what I mean. I
don't really vote this. last time I
voted um just because I didn't you voted
what did you vote? Did you vote for
pro-choicers?
I voted for Biden. Yes. Yeah. See, there
you go. There you go. So, and you think
that you're doing God a favor somehow.
You're spiritual when you're going to
answer to God for the choices you make
even legally. So, let me repeat the
question again because you did vote for
a pro-choicer, someone who's also for
transgenderism. If you can be used of
God to work in within the legal system
to legislate according to God's will,
shame on you if you don't and God's
judgment will be upon you. I'm not
saying you go put a gun to someone and
saying you better believe. But if the
system allows you to vote for people who
will legislate in a manner that pleases
God and you didn't, God's wrath be upon
you. And that's why I have a hard time
voting for either side. I didn't, you
know what I mean? But you still went
ahead and voted for Biden. Why did you
vote then?
Just cuz I didn't like the way uh Trump
was taking this this country. So you
don't like the way Trump is taking the
country, but you're okay with Biden
taking the country to transgenderism,
pro-
homosexuality, silencing traditional
conservative
Christians, and giving a platform for a
transgender dude who thinks he's a woman
to be part of his office. And you're
okay with that? Wow, man. No. No, no.
I'm I what I'm okay is if he wants to do
his thing, he or she wants to do his
thing. They have when they die, they
have to answer to God. So, why don't you
then vote for Trump and let Trump do his
or his thing?
Because a lot of the programs Trump
Trump was saying like all these
prolifers are okay with when the baby's
in the womb, but once it's out of the
womb, they want to take away all these
programs that would help these babies,
that would help these children that
would grow up in these. So, let me
guess. So, so it's better to murder the
child? No, I'm not saying that. No,
brother. You're not. You're listen to
yourself. You didn't want to vote for
Trump, though. He's pro- life because
once a child is born, take away programs
to make it hard for that child and his
upbringing. So, let me then vote for
someone who's okay for terminating the
life in the womb. Yeah. Okay. That's
consistent. It It's It's not. And I This
is why I struggle. This is why I'm
calling you right now to try to
understand. You know, I like I said, all
the programs that the right wants to
take away from these kids when they're
born, that's What rights do they want to
take away from the kids? Explain it to
me. They want to they want to take away
welfare, food stamps, housing, all you
know. Um, let's go with that. Let's
let's go with that. Okay, let's let's
now take that into
consideration. How has welfare because
I' I've been raised in the city. I've
seen what welfare does. How has welfare
helped these
children get out of the welfare system
and get set on their feet and become
independent as opposed to being a means
by which to handicap them and enslave
them to a system where they feel
entitled to all these benefits producing
in many cases, not always, I'm not
generalizing, people who know since
welfare will take care of them, what's
the point of going and trying to get on
my feet and become independent so I can
break away from the system.
Well, I I grew up on welfare. My mom was
on welfare. My dad was in prison my
whole life. Yes. Well, your mom You're
giving an exception, right? Did you get
out of the welfare system? Yeah. I'm not
on I'm not any How many of the people
that you grew up with are off the
welfare system?
Um, most of the kids I grew up with were
on welfare, you know. Um, where are
they? None of them are What's that?
Where are they now?
They all have jobs and houses and all
that stuff just like me. Okay.
So, percentage-wise of all the people on
the welfare system that you know, how
many of them broke out of that system
and became independent and financially
well off and responsible?
Um, roughly like percentage 80 85% I
would say. I I know it's you'd probably
be smoking. No, that's not true. the
people that I know. No, I didn't say
what you said. I said
percentagewise. Percentagewise in
America, how many people on the welfare
system have broken off the system and
become independent and financially
stable? So, they don't depend on the
government anymore. I have no clue. I I
I don't know. Yeah, it actually if you
look at it, it is alarmingly low. So,
this system doesn't help. It creates an
environment where you enslave people to
a system and that that becomes a pattern
generation after generation because if
welfare worked, how do you
explain these ghettos and inner city
problems that you face all over the
country such as
Chicago? Because it does not work. Yes,
when people legitimately need help, of
course you step in to help. But to
perpetuate a system that only reproduces
people or enslaved to the system and do
not break off the system, you're only
contributing to chaos and decay. You're
not solving the disease. You're only
prolonging the disease generation after
generation after generation.
Okay? But um but come back to the issue.
What did you want to ask me about
abortion? Let's go back to abortion
anyway. Well, I just I just like I said,
it was the the the I don't understand
like the people that are uh pro-life,
they care about the womb, but when
they're out, like I said, those
programs, they're taking away from those
kids because most of those kids are that
are going to be aborted are coming from
horrible parents. Either the dad's not
there. So then why don't you give them
up for adoption and so wealthy people
can adopt them? Okay. I I was in prison
when I went to 19 when I was 19. And I
met a lot of people in there who grew up
on those in foster care and all those. I
didn't say foster care. I said adoption.
Foster care. I know it's a corrupt
system, but you're only making my case.
The system is corrupt. The system
produces destruction. The system is set
up to promote decadence. I didn't say
foster system. I know people in foster
system who are abused. What I'm saying
is give them up to adoptive parents.
Parents who want to adopt them.
Okay. But if there was so many people
that were adopting that, then we
wouldn't have these programs like foster
care. You know, actually, you know why
you have it? Because the adoptive the
adoption makes it almost impossible for
you to adopt a child because of all the
red tape that someone has to go through
and the high cost. Why then put these
restrictions on adoption? Why not make
adoption very accessible to qualified
healthy parents instead of making them
jump through red tapes and also pay
exorbitant amounts of money to adopt a
child? I agree with you. I I'm not
disagreeing with that. But who's
creating these systems? The very people
that you voted in.
They're uh they're putting the red tape
up. I I it's your legislators that are
creating such a wicked evil system, a
system that's
perpetuating,
destruction, decadence, and people born
in bondage. In fact, let's go with
Planned Parenthood. Who started Planned
Parenthood and why? I don't know. I I
don't know much about Planned
Parenthood. Planned Parenthood, which is
the the supposedly the health care
provider for women, you know, which is
the number one abortion mill, was
started by a woman whose own reported
words was to
build Planned Parenthoods in inner
cities in order to decrease the black
and
Hispanic community to try to abort as
many black and Hispanic children to
bring down the black and Hispanic
population.
But isn't there just as many Caucasians
getting aborted as black and whites? Of
course, but that was not her plan.
Notice what you did. I like how you just
did a Muslim tactic. I know white people
take advantage of the system. I'm
talking about the founder. Why did she
What was her design? What was her goal?
To create Planned Parenthoods to try to
bring down the black and Hispanic
population.
Like I said, I I don't know much about
Planned Parenthood. I know that they
they uh have a much What's that? Are you
okay with that?
No. No, I'm not. Like I said, this
subject you're feeding into a system
that was designed to destroy the black
and Hispanic population.
Okay. I guess I got to do a little more
research. Why don't you do me a favor,
brother? I'm not trying to be harsh with
you.
That's fine. I want you to go study who
started Planned Parenthood and why. And
then I want you to do a little more
studying on the welfare system. Has it
worked? Then you're going to better
understand and be in a better position
to see why someone like Trump wanted to
slowly remove it. Not overnight. That's
not what he's going to do. He wanted to
set laws in motion so that in time
people who are on welfare will be people
who really qualify for welfare, not
healthy teenagers or healthy young
adults who are too lazy to go work
because why should they work? They're
just going to suck the life out of the
welfare system. That's what Trump was
intending to do. And I'm not pro Trump,
by the way. Anyway, brother. Good night,
brother. God bless you. Come back to me
when you've done your research. All
right. God bless you, too, Sam. Take
care. Bye-bye.
The the hypocrisy of these people. You
saw the hypocrisy, guys. And by the way,
I don't want to get into politics. I'm
not pro Trump, pro Biden. I'm pro-
Jesus. And anyone who legislates in a
manner that glorifies Christ will get my
vote. But you saw he said, "No, I'm not
trying to attack Trump." And that's
exactly what he did. You guys caught it,
right?